John Tolliver I have to start first
about your book on great white father's
ask you about that name because people
have seen John looks like Taliaferro and
it's not where did you get the name
Tolliver Italian originally I'm sure my
ancestors came here several hundred
years ago and the pronounciation got
stepped on pretty hard my father will
say that it it means Eisenhower in
Italian which is true pronounced
Tolliver great white father's it's when
you look at the cover of the book who is
that first of all Lincoln and you can't
miss it for being Mount Rushmore what's
this book about this book is obviously
about Mount Rushmore I've was one of
those people who didn't go to Mount
Rushmore in the back of the station
wagon when I was a child I went more
recently in the mid 90s and I was struck
in a couple of different ways one is
Mount Rushmore as a work of art but the
other was Mount Rushmore as an artifact
of the idea that archeologists came upon
this colossal carving in the Black Hills
in the center of our nation ten thousand
years from now and treated it the way we
now treat the pyramids or something like
that what does it say about the
civilization that created it who are
these men on the mountain how did they
get here who carved it what are the the
values behind this and so that was my
approach so that took when I started
digging as a archaeologist if you will I
had to know what came before I wanted to
look at the community around it the
Mount Rushmore is a tourist attraction
along with being America's shrine of
democracy it draws two and a half
million people a year there is an
immense community around them
of water slides and and paintball
courses and reptile gardens that have
grown up around Mount Rushmore III
wanted to understand the culture where
is it it is in the Black Hills of South
Dakota a long way from a lot of places
and in fact that's why it is there in
the 1920s when the idea came to a man
named Don Robinson South Dakota was in
the midst of a Great Depression a
depression that carried over into the
depression of the 30s even and he
thought well how can we get Americans to
come to our region of the world he was
it was conceived as the next leg under
the economic table of in South Dakota
and it worked what year was it started
officially started 1927 the the idea was
conceived in 24 the sculptor Gutzon
Borglum came in 1925 when was it
finished 1941 almost minutes before
Pearl Harbor who's on the mountain I
know that the answer to that question
George Washington and then to his left
the viewers right is Thomas Jefferson
Theodore Roosevelt and Abraham Lincoln
first picture in the book is of this man
right here and holding a little boy who
is it that is Gutzon Borglum the
sculptor of Mount Rushmore I knew
nothing really about him until I had
been to Mount Rushmore and nothing about
him until I started digging into the
archives at the Library of Congress
about him and at that point I really had
to fight hard not to write a biography
of Gutzon Borglum because he is such a
terrifically fascinating complex a
colossal figure in his own right of
forgotten today in art circles one of
the great
and most important sculptors of the
early 20th century in this picture who's
he holding that is his son Lincoln who
of course was named after his great hero
Abraham Lincoln who is there's a model
of a sculpture and the also in that
photo which is called the seeded Lincoln
which is front of the courthouse in
Newark New Jersey one of his very first
efforts at colossal sculpture
I remember your book right did when
Lincoln was 29 and his father died he
took over what was left of the Mount
Rushmore
yeah the Sun was the the Protege went
with his father on all of his sculptural
jobs starting with Stone Mountain
Georgia which was initially a Portland
project and that he would tag along with
him and he climbed the mountain for the
first time with his father as a teenager
and eventually became his right-hand man
and took over the day-to-day operation
and when the father Gutzon died in the
spring of 1941 the the son took over and
finished the mountain where hey where
could we find Gutzon borglum's
work in this country starting with the
Capitol Rotunda there is a wonderful
bust of Lincoln that if you go look at
that you understand how Borglum then got
to Mount Rushmore it was done forgive me
dates fly out of my head during the
Roosevelt presidency I want to say 1907
but I might be oh wait it's a large head
of Lincoln done in marble it if it were
a full figure it would have been on a
man some eight to ten feet tall we think
of Lincoln as a with dark features with
with with the dark eyes all the famous
photographs of Matthew by Matthew
we think of this character as of Lincoln
as in shadow a lot and Borglum did of
this bust of Lincoln in in white marble
and it is in a gorgeous gorgeous
treatment of him Lincoln's son said it
was the best piece ever done of them the
is a wonderful sculpture of general
Philip Sheridan in Dupont Circle here in
Washington
unfortunately borglum's
what would have been borgen's biggest
work even bigger than Mount Rushmore
was never completed and ultimately
destroyed and that is at Stone Mountain
Georgia what year was this picture tiger
that picture was taken probably in the
late teens or no probably early teens
after the Civil War there was a you know
a huge rush to create memorials to the
fallen on but in both the north and the
south and the the south after it sort of
caught its breath decided it needed to
have its memorials to match those in the
North Stone Mountain is this huge
granite formation 16 miles outside of
Atlanta and the Daughters of the
Confederacy thought that wouldn't it be
nice to have a little shrine there
perhaps a little niche at the bottom
where you could come and ponder the the
heroes of the Lost Cause and maybe some
busts carved into the side of it and
they invited Gutzon Borglum to come down
and look at it and he saw this canvas
that was acres and acres hundreds and
hundreds of square feet and he said we
need to give it its due and he can
a cavalcade of cavalry and artillery
marching down the face of the mountain
ending up with Jefferson Davis robert e
lee and Stonewall Jackson at the fore
unfortunately he fell in with the wrong
crowd down there and the Klan was was
really n in 1915 same time as the movie
Birth of a Nation was coming out and
Borglum who who liked the political
thrust in Perry and was a considers him
sidered himself a bit of a rebel himself
joined in with the Klan and ultimately
when the Klan got to fighting amongst
itself they threw Borglum off the
mountain you said he got to be close
friends with the the Grand Dragon the
number two person in the Klan DC
Stevenson from Indiana yeah the I guess
the the greatest myth about the Klan is
that they were all sort of redneck a
bunch of louts from the south well what
we've forgotten is that when the with
the second coming of the Klan beginning
in 1915 there was a through to the early
20s it was a much more middle class much
more the members were much more from the
establishment and they weren't just from
the south the majority of Klan members
in the 1920s were from the southwest and
the Midwest was a huge political force
in the 1924 presidential election the
Klan insisted it could bring six
thousand voters to the to the polling
places this fellow named DC Stevenson
was the the head of the Klan in Indiana
it is inauguration of an estimated a
hundred thousand people
clansmen and robes came to the
inauguration he was and he was in a
power play with the clan leaders in
Atlanta there was some thought that the
Klan could could get a candidate elected
to the presidency even for a while the
program was fired from the Stone
Mountain project when and why fired why
because of ego this a man who's gonna
carved mountains the statues in the
mountains does not have a small ego he
was fired because they thought he wasn't
spending enough time there he was he was
fired because he sided with this fellow
from Indiana DC Stephenson who was
trying to take over control of the Klan
in Atlanta he was fired because of he
complained he wasn't getting paid enough
and they literally ran him out of town
he was he destroyed his models so that
no one else could follow them there was
a rest warrant issued this is in in 1925
and they chased him out of town across
the Georgia state line a bunch of the
sheriff and a bunch of Klan thugs chased
him into Georgia and so he effectively
fled Georgia to South Dakota just at the
time things were falling apart in
Georgia he was getting letters saying
hey we'd like to carve something out
here too what if you go down there just
to a mountain today what do you see
there there is a carving that poor girl
AHA got in partly through the robert e
lee head and a little bit into the
stonewall jackson that was blasted off
the mountain it took to the Nixon
administration to complete Stone
Mountain that there is
a carving of the Confederate generals
that Borglum had intended a car but
there and by an entirely different group
of artists you say he was married twice
and his first wife was eighteen years
older than he was
what were their circumstances
poor grooms birth parents for Mormon in
fact his father was polygamist he's
parents were Danish immigrants came over
with the with a wave of Mormon converts
in the 1860s and they all made the long
trek out to Utah and his father's wife
wife's sisters if you follow me there
came over a year later and his father
took the sister on as the second wife
and then the father decided he didn't
want to be a Mormon anymore and and the
prejudice against polygamy was very
strong and the Mormons were greatly
persecuted just part of the reason why
they ended up in Utah and so the father
decided to abandon one of his wives and
that happened to be Goodson borglum's
mother so when he was six years old all
of a sudden his his mother was banished
and disappeared from his life long way
of answering the question why did he
marry a woman 18 years older pop shrinks
would suggest that he's looking for his
mother how long did he stay married to
her he stayed married to her a lot
longer than he stayed with her who was
she he was an artist he met her in
California she was very talented a
landscape painter and I think she
brought him into the art world out there
and encouraged him and they went to
Europe together and spent nearly 11
years and Europe 1890s to the
in the century to 1901
Borglum and so their life together were
was his husband and wife but as fellow
artists and and that was also part of
what was going on I think he got to a
certain level of of talent and and maybe
didn't need her anymore and but in the
Europe he he went to Europe as a painter
and came home the sculptor and the
reason was Rodin Rodin was after
Michelangelo probably the most
influential sculptor I can think of and
he happened to be at his Rodin happened
to be at his height in Paris when
Borglum showed up and it turned his head
and turned his world around not just
because of the sheer talent of Rodin but
Rodin was a celebrity he was he was is
Rodin didn't respond to the anybody else
but himself and he was a very powerful
potent colorful person and I think for
the first time being around Rodin
Borglum realized that an artist could be
more than an artist and an artist could
be a celebrity how well did he know
Rodin not that well and it's a little
hard to determine but I wrote an you
knew him well enough so we're know that
Rodin remembered Borglum and when
Borglum got back to the United States
Rodin wrote letters to certain people
saying this guy's good you ought to pay
attention to him and there were real
letters of entree that really gave
Borglum the boost when he got back you
listed at one point your book the
different places that Borglum lived in
his life and I want to tick him off and
get you just to tell us a little bit
about why he was there first was Idaho
yeah born in Idaho the the Mormon thing
when his parents moved just north of the
Utah border and Idaho when he was born
Nebraska father left the Mormon Church
went back
to medical school in Nebraska family
with him England gone to Europe to study
art sell art how long do you live there
a couple years three years Spain that's
sort of a wilderness here he we don't
know that much about him went down there
to paint to study not clear how young
years yeah we're talking about in his
30s France as years when he was studying
sculpture and working absorbing Rodin
and the and the bows art style their New
York where he settled when he came back
from Europe in 1901 there was so much
sculpture being commissions there that
was that was the Art Center of for
sculpture anyway where do you meet his
second wife on the boat back from Europe
under what circumstances she was coming
home from finishing a PhD this is a
woman who got a PhD from the University
of Berlin one of the very first women
ever to receive a PhD there spoke about
six different languages her parents had
been Protestant missionaries in Turkey
and he fell in love with her on the boat
how long were they married till he she
survived him so they were married guys
putting me on the spot on the math more
than 30 years how many children did he
have by both women none by the first by
the that was one of the reasons for the
breakup of the first marriage and to
Lincoln who we've talked about and
another a daughter named Mary Ellis who
has just passed away this year
did you know her no I did not he lived
in Connecticut yeah
moved to New York and then fought in a
state near Stanford you down long was he
there well he kept it for a long time
but he he got he borrowed mining got
behind and then he started doing these
commissions in Georgia
in South Dakota he'd moved to Texas for
a while he thought there were a lot of
big jobs there so while he kept his
estate which he called Borg land by the
way he didn't go back there this month
at much how long did he live in Georgia
Stone Mountain was begun in 1915 but the
war broke out so he he left that job for
a while came back in twenty-two and left
in twenty-five how long was he in San
Antonio part of the year from 1925
through til about nineteen thirty six or
seven did he ever live in DC Marston no
he was here often he was this he was a
great political operator he knew
everybody he could go up to the door of
the White House and knock on the door
and they'd let him in beginning with
Roosevelt through to Roosevelt he would
stay at the he was a member of the MIT
of when's the club in town we met in
Holland club I'm getting it confused
Century Club in New York metropolitan
here yeah he also lived for a while as
you say in California and what was how
long was he out there briefly when it
was a very young man teenager and then
when he got married several years later
you say that the Mount Rushmore cost
nine hundred eighty nine thousand
dollars in 1941 money I guess or in that
back in those years but that the feds
paid for eight hundred thirty six
thousand yeah there's a great story
about that of they thought they could
raise the money through philanthropy
in nineteen in the late twenties there
was a lot of wealth in the United States
but before they've got very far got
going very far I'm not rushing for the
of course the stock market crashed and
all of a sudden the people who had any
money were holding had lost it or they
were holding on to what they had in the
summer of 1927 two years before the
crash President Calvin Coolidge was
looking for a place to spend his summer
vacation the White House was being
renovated his son had died from a
blister he'd gotten playing tennis
without socks on the White House lawn in
the end Grace and Calvin Coolidge were
saddened by that and did not want to
spend another summer's in the White
House
so they went casting about for a place
to stay and every state in the nation
wanted the President as dull as he was
to come there for summer vacation
somehow the Black Hills of South Dakota
won that lottery and Calvin Coolidge and
his wife arrived in the summer of 1927
by total coincidence it was when Borglum
was just getting to work on Mount
Rushmore and Coolidge said he wasn't he
was on vacation he wasn't gonna give any
speeches but it was also the summer of
Charles Lindbergh flying the
transatlantic flight and so air air
miracles were on everybody's tongue so
Borglum hired a plane flew over the
summer White House and dropped a note
onto the lawn inviting the president the
first lady to the dedication of Mount
Rushmore and they accepted and Coolidge
like so many others was taken by Borglum
and his talent in his charm and his just
his forcefulness and said when I get
back to Washington I'm going to tell
Secretary of Treasury Andrew Mellon
to help you out here and so what began
as what should have been a privately
funded project ended up being a publicly
funded project he also broke it down and
suggested over 17 years he made an
average of ten thousand dollars a year
on the project and he thought he was
only gonna work there part-time after
all they could only work on Mount
Rushmore in this warm months it's a
tough winter up there in the Black Hills
and he thought he could dash off to
other parts of the country down to Texas
where there was a lot of oil money and
people wanted big monuments to various
causes and he thought he could do that
with his left hand and and with his son
and others supervised Mount Rushmore
didn't work out and he he was bound to
the mountain like Prometheus where did
you get interested in this in the first
place I went there I was just it was one
of those pull off the interstate deals
almost and what year about 1996 and I
pulled in there and I was just I didn't
know what I thought here was this
massive colossal sculpture in the middle
of the nation
it's a monument to an idea I mean the
statute it doesn't even compare to the
Statue of Liberty after all which is
there at New York Harbor where Ellis
Island is where the immigrants came in
here is a monument not so much to a
person it's not a monument to a battle
such as Gettysburg it's a shrine of
democracy it's it's a monument to an
idea forced me to want to think about
those ideas
it made me it it just opened up a lot of
my pores intellectually and I wanted to
sort out what I really thought how many
books have been written about this Oh
perhaps it doesn't and how is yours
different the previous books have done a
very good job of telling the
nitty-gritty of how Mount Rushmore was
carved which is a wonderful fascinating
story as interesting and as heroic as
say the accounts of building the Golden
Gate Bridge the Hoover Dam or something
like that how 200 out-of-work miners
were turned into skilled stone carvers
by Gutzon Borglum the process of taking
a small model and turning it into large
heads on a on a living mountain
fascinating story and I tell that story
also I wanted to go beyond that and talk
about what was there before how it was
conceived and and also very much
how Mount Rushmore has been received I
think sort of one of the lessons that
I've learned or one of the things I've
thought about it even more so in the
last year is as we as Americans put our
values and our ideals before the public
and say this is what we stand for but we
can't guarantee how they will be
received well Mount Rushmore is very
representative of that this is truly are
more than anything I can think of is our
monument of who we are what we stand for
these four presidents embodying various
American values and so
Mount Rushmore has been interpreted not
everybody receives that message in the
same way including Native Americans well
this picture here of him is that which a
Lincoln statue is at next to him that is
the bus that is in the Capitol rotunda
if you look at him in that picture I
don't know what you see but it looks to
me like he's not a very happy man
Borglum interpretation of Lincoln was
not as a great orator or as a statesman
or as a rail splitter that Lincoln
Borglum was fascinated by the pensive
reflective Lincoln of he one of his one
of the other Lincoln's that's the the
seated Lincoln that sent before the
courthouse in Newark is born called his
Lincoln at Gethsemane during the Civil
War Lincoln President Lincoln would go
out into the garden after receiving bad
news from the front and and and and look
inward and Borglum I think more than
anyone else
saw that side of Lincoln and having done
a couple of Lincoln sculptures act there
were so many done after Lincoln's death
it was it was it was an industry doing
Lincoln statues there's one everywhere
we all can think of one including the
Lincoln Memorial which Borglum was very
jealous of he he had wanted that to be
his Commission he thought Lincoln
belonged to him one of the reasons why
he did Mount Rushmore was to show those
people in Washington what Lincoln really
should look like we could go back to the
picture of him in this expression you
paint in the book a man who at one point
or another was anti-semitic anti-black
anti-indian
that's pretty strong way to put it I the
evidence of anti-semitism is a little
more evident I wouldn't say that he was
anti black or anti Indian yeah there his
involvement with the Klan was not just
he was not just being opportunistic it
wasn't just a way to gain power when he
was working in clout when he was working
in Georgia he actually believed that the
Klan platform was a worthy platform and
his letters and correspondents are full
of anti-semitic rhetoric the Indian
story's a little more complicated before
you go to the industry let me just ask
you about Eugene Meyer who was Jewish
and owned the Washington Post here what
was his relationship with him he called
him a [ __ ] you say [ __ ] yeah
arguably Morgan would have not gotten we
wouldn't be here talking about this if
it weren't for Eugene why are you Jean
Meyer was an investment banker in New
York when Borglum did his first Lincoln
bust Meyer decided to buy it and donate
it to the US government it was placed in
the White House
briefly and then placed in perpetuity in
the rotunda that really gave that really
gave Borglum his entree he's Canton
Graham's father
yes he Meier then went from his New York
investment bank banking business moved
to Washington worked in the Wilson
administration some other and miss and
bought the Washington Post his daughter
is his daughter was Katharine Graham
Mayer also loaned Borglum a ton of money
really was his patron to buy land in
Connecticut where he was going to set up
his estate and studio and Borglum never
paid him back here he was an artist in
that sense that money didn't when he
didn't represent money to him and
when Meyer was very patient with him
very persistent though and Borglum just
wouldn't pay him back and then
ultimately wrote some letters back to
him and says you know isn't that just
you know you'd is being like an ultra
Jew to do this and started calling him a
[ __ ] and and it really hurt Meyers
feelings needless to say and and Borglum
alienated a very good friend and a true
supporter you say that he promised women
that he put a woman somewhere on the
mountain and then he promised the
Indians that he would put an Indian at
the Eagles Nest wherever that was oh
that's a wonderful story about susan b
anthony there just as he was getting to
the end of mount rushmore there was a
national campaign of women's movement of
to get some memorial somewhere of susan
b anthony and there was a woman named
Rose arnold powell who took it on as her
life's mission to promote the image of
the susan b anthony and correspondent
with Borglum for years and years and
years and he backhanded Lee what sort of
wink and a nod said yeah we'll find a
place somewhere on the mountain for her
and she enlisted Eleanor Roosevelt to to
push for it and there was actually some
legislation run up to ad susan b anthony
to mount rushmore and never got anywhere
Borglum had a sort of noble savage
appreciation of Native Americans the
Indians were on the reservation the Pine
Ridge Reservation is not far from Mount
Rushmore it is today and has been for a
long time one of the the poorest places
in America the Lakota Sioux were one of
the fiercest strongest
tribes on the plains and how far they
fell they had defeated Custer and the
army wanted him to pay for so Borglum
had developed a some sympathy for them
went down to the reservation did things
for them they came up to them just down
a couple karma Carlos fool I mean
everyone cars full of yeah their daring
enough during the 30s when things were
Dust Bowl times he made sure that they
got some food and blankets let me let me
back up a little
Mount Rushmore and the Black Hills are
the holy mount to Native Americans
particularly the Lakota Sioux Indians
some of their most sacred rituals and
ceremonies are held there there their
vision quests their Sun dances there is
nothing more sacred to these Indians
than the Black Hills how many are there
out there now I mean Oak Otis to our
left I don't know I can't cite the
tribal registry but thirty forty
thousand I think would be on the
reservation and then in the Hills isn't
Darren don't they have a claim right now
to a certain amount of money that's
being kept for them you might remember
the the Bradley bill the well there was
at the Supreme Court there was a lawsuit
filed back in the 20s saying that the
Black Hills the treaty had been violated
in the Black Hills had been taken
unjustly from the Sioux it worked all
the way through the courts up into the
80s and it went to the court of claims
it was up and a ward was given as I've
held by the Supreme Court payment for
this breach of of treaty
well the Lakota Sioux said we don't want
this money we want our Black Hills back
we take this money it's like a wampum we
don't want it and so it's it's an a
trust fund in Washington six hundred
million dollars now Shannon County where
pie
Ridge Reservation is is the poorest
County in the United States six hundred
million dollars would help but this is
the strength this is the passion of the
sue this is how badly they want the
Black Hills back they want Mount
Rushmore back who who has claimed
specifically to that six hundred million
dollars right now the Sioux tribes of
South Dakota so it would be if they took
the money to be dispersed him they would
be dispersed yeah and I can't remember
what the number would come out to but
you know several thousand dollars per
person or that obviously maybe wouldn't
be divvied person by person but anyway
this is all moot because if there was
one thing that the Lakota agree on is we
don't want the money we want what was
rightfully ours and they have a they
have a good argument
so the eagle's nest where is it and why
did he promise the Sioux that he'd put a
face up there that's a funny story that
Indians who Borglum loved and wanted to
help came to them and said look we have
our heroes too we want some recognition
that we were here first and we had great
men also and he said well I'll find a
place for you as he said we're the
eagle's nest he was speaking in that
sort of white man's version of an Indian
lingo but he was a little vague about
that and never really did follow through
and what happened was another sculptor
showed up in the Black Hills man named
Korczak Ziolkowski who went on and took
that idea and ran with it and and I'm
sure you're familiar with this Crazy
Horse Memorial which is many times the
size of Mount Rushmore and it's a work
in progress and how far it's even more
controversial than Mount
was about 19 20 miles away from Mount
Rushmore yeah that's about right and
it's still being built and it will be
built for many more generations this
Manjula cuff ski is dead as children are
working on it
wait go back and tell the story while
you're talking also about the eagle's
nest about how the fellow that started
Crazy Horse worked for Borglum for a
while yeah he was a sculptor from
Connecticut
I mean came out and worked for Borglum
for about three weeks and people who
sculptors in general but sculptors of
colossal sculpture are pretty headstrong
and they didn't get along and Tolkowsky
was fired from the job after three weeks
Borglum said get out of here
there was rumored to have been a fight
between Borglum son Lincoln and Hough
ski on the mountain over a chain of
command or who knows what and anyway
they sent this young guy packing and
this was in the 30s World War two came
and nobody did any work and on the
mountain and Joe Kopp ski came back in
the late 40s and said I've got an even
bigger idea very controversial from the
Native Americans standpoint and arguably
Crazy Horse the great Lakota holy man
chief warrior gave his life to keep
white people from the Black Hills and
you say that they don't and now they're
building this immense the memorial which
is it was to him but it's an enormous
magnet for tourists and he said he
didn't even look like well no one knows
what Crazy Horse looked like he refused
to be photographed you know he refused
to sign a treaty who used to sleep in a
bed so when they had the
inauguration when they had the
dedication when they began work on Crazy
Horse their model was there and there
were some at that point there were still
some survivors of Little Bighorn and
some people have known Crazy Horse who
came and I said doesn't look like a
friend quick thing on the money when you
go to Mount Rushmore does it cost
anything to go see it the original
legislation said it's got to be free but
the parking cost do you pay a parking
fee a parking fee you know eight bucks
is that what it is I can't really ask
some like eight bucks but when you go
over to Crazy Horse what's the deal
there
oh it's private that's private
enterprise that's the American dream
yeah it costs eight bucks to get in or
how many per car and again 19 per car 19
dollars a car where you load it up yeah
I think that's right and the family's
still there what do you have ten kids he
had a bunch of kids yeah they're all
hard-working and dedicated to their
father's dream and his widow is also
there and she's a force force of nature
herself and uh very well regarded by a
broad range of people but in the end
Gutzon Borglum didn't put an indian on
the mountain didn't put a woman on the
mountain but God did he say he got away
with promising he would
yeah well the issue dropped with respect
to Mount Rushmore as soon as the Crazy
Horse thing it came on you got to
understand that the Indians consider
blowing up carving into their sacred
Black Hills is like gouging flesh from
the breast of their mother so even if
it's a memorial to their one of their
their their greatest leaders the irony
of blowing up the Black Hills to honor
Crazy Horse doesn't sit well with a lot
of Native Americans a lot of Native
Americans support it I would suggest
that a majority don't which book is just
for you third book what were your first
two first was the biography of the
Western artist Charles Russell
the second book was called Tarzan
forever
biography of Edgar Rice Burroughs the
creator of Tarzan I'd like to take these
American images the cowboy and and and
hold them up and treat them as sort of a
Rorschach of our culture where do you
live now
I live in two places Austin Texas and
also in Montana a little bit outside of
Yellowstone National Park why the two
places
they're both great places I can't make
up my mind
mérida Texan moved to Austin in 1979
I've knocked around in journalism for a
few years about ten years ago decided
that books was going to be the way to go
and bought a little house in Montana or
go up when it's hot in Texas when you
were in journalism before books what did
you do last job was with a Newsweek I
was a senior editor in New York and a
briefly a bureau chief in Los Angeles
for how long three years where did you
grow up native of Baltimore left as aged
nine upstate New York schools in New
England where secondary school Phillips
Exeter Academy College Harvard studied
what at Harvard that's a tough question
I always say education is what you get
when you're going to college I was an
English major
now when you wrote this book any
research that researchers then wrote it
did you feel better about Mount Rushmore
and what it symbolizes or worse after
you finished that is a good question I
felt better I mean I what ifwhat ice
rink from what unsettled me about Mount
Rushmore was the story was too
simplified that America can be boiled
down into a bumper sticker I like it
when the when things are a little
Messier the fact that the creator of our
shrine of to
see also had been a Klansman that this
is a little more complicated there that
our values as good as they are our
message of democracy comes from a stew
that is it is not pure good people can
do bad things bad people can do good
things I like that part of the
discussion of our American civilization
nationalism is is a is a complicated
subject and I think I got at it fairly
successfully through this book this book
is much more than just a book about a
couple of hundred guys chiseling four
faces on a big rock it's really about
who are these men why we worship them
what are the what are the values that
they are projecting into the future one
of the other things you did was write
about Keystone right where Mount
Rushmore is and the the the rebuilding
of the facilities of National Park
Service want to show that we were out
there over a year ago and did a program
on it but those who didn't see it you
can see on the screen there that's the
Mount Rushmore Visitors Center and how
new is this completed in 1998 and it's a
wonderful structure of Mount Rushmore
gets two and a half million people a
year visitor so that's over most of them
coming over about a six month period
Yellowstone Park which is two million
acres gets roughly three million
visitors a year Mount Rushmore which is
as in terms of the the acreage that
people can actually set foot on it's
like twelve
so it's packed it's a city at the end of
a long highway so Mount Rushmore
they had finally somebody said look
we've got a traffic jam here we've got
to deal with the number of visitors so
this is the Avenue of the flags you come
in through this wonderful colonnade
visitor center and
it's like going down the center center
aisle of a cathedral with these columns
I think they did a wonderful job these
are the flags of all the united states
and territories and so you walk down it
and then you come to this viewing
terrace at the end and it's like
standing on the at the bow of a ship all
of that parking facilities and the
visitor centers are all of sudden behind
you and it's just it's just you in the
mountain you could be an immense crowd
in a summer day of twenty thirty
thousand people and feel quite alone
with this sculpture and I think that's a
great achievement of the Park Service
the face that's hardest to see when you
just stand there is the one in the
middle are not the middle but it's the
the theater Roosevelt faced and Gutzon
Borglum had quite a history with this
man when did he first meet him Theodore
Roosevelt he had done a little bit work
for a little bit of carving for
Roosevelt for his house in Oyster Bay is
Long Island he did a Lincoln this first
Lincoln bus that Eugene Meyer had
commissioned Roosevelt admired it was in
the White House briefly and what and
Roosevelt made sure it got into the
Rotunda then uh
Borglum n Rushmore in some ways the same
Borglum and roosevelt was in some ways
the same person they were they were
stocky than the bridge leti mustache
they believed in this strain he was life
they were both very athletic and Borglum
worshipped Roosevelt and got to know him
personally and as he was call and recall
in 1912 when the 1980 Roosevelt decided
not to run for re-election Taft came in
Roosevelt didn't like the how Taft
had run the White House decided to run
again as a bull moose in 1912 and
Borglum became very involved in his
presidential race and
there was immense amount of personal
correspondence it's hard to imagine
Borglum without Roosevelt in the picture
as well well he named says he was police
commissioner in New York yeah that's
right did he get on the mountain because
of their personal friendship I think so
Roosevelt died in 1919 Mount Rushmore
was conceived in 1925 there was a big
there was immense amount of money raised
for Roosevelt Memorial what a lot of
people forget is the where the Jefferson
Memorial Memorial is now in Washington
was supposed to be the Roosevelt
Memorial they had the money in place to
build a Roosevelt Teddy Roosevelt
memorial there but then and some
Democrats came forward and it was this
centennial of the death of of Jefferson
said look there's no Jefferson Memorial
here so there was a big movement for a
Roosevelt Memorial Borglum had known
Roosevelt and said hey I want to be the
guy to do that it wasn't happening in
Washington he said I'm gonna put my guy
out here in South Dakota
also remember that Roosevelt after his
wife had died and gone out and been a
rancher in South Dakota briefly you also
write a lot about but not a lot but at
the end you write about Keystone and one
man who seems to have done very well
there Keystone is the community closest
to Mount Rushmore it's the little
tourist town at the bottom of the
mountain with all the little gift shops
and ice cream stands and I wanted to
meet the movers and shakers of this town
because after all Mount Rushmore was
conceived as a way to draw tourists to
western South Dakota and it did that in
spades I met a wonderful man named Bill
Durst who owns or controls most of the
businesses and Keystone's and and two or
three of the hotels the definition of an
entrepreneur he'd grown up in the black
hills work and he is in a sense taking
the borglum's lead and
armed out the side of the mountains and
Keystone to put in hotels he has just
completed a hotel several years ago
called the president's view where you
can sit in your room or some of the
rooms and look across at Mount Rushmore
it's it's the final shoe dropping I
suppose on the dream of Gutzon Borglum
and the other people in the Black Hills
who wanted Mount Rushmore to be carved
that if we build it they will come
well they came and then this is the
building that are coming in how many of
the stores is he own guys what is it 20
or something uh it's hard to remember
the numbers from my own but yeah but he
is the he's got boardwalk in Park Place
and and a lot of the other cards on the
Monopoly board there I can't tell you
you know Mount Rushmore was when it was
conceived was was remote you drove
across dirt roads that were there were
scarcely any bridges across the major
rivers in the West and and you drove for
days and you looked up in the hill and
there were this carving and now when you
drive across South Dakota it's it's wall
drugged reptile garden bear country USA
and from they come at you for hundreds
of miles
Mount Rushmore is is the engine that
drives that economy but it's it's just
one of the things people come to see
when they come to this region it it was
a case of build Mount Rushmore so we can
get a tourism in how far is it from
Rapid City that half an hour 20 months
and one of the things you said about
your firm mr. Durst is when a bus would
drive up outside the he'd say that's
worth $5,000 right there well he's a
frank man and I I really enjoyed his
company he was quite open took me in but
yeah hey you know tour buses come in to
his hotel and I when I first interviewed
him this big bus of Midwestern senior
citizens pulled up and outside his
window and
airbrakes went off and he says you hear
that and I said he said what is that I
said it's the brakes he said no that's
$5,000 they come and stay in his hotels
he to this restaurant he is one of the
great visionaries of that area in the
end who made the selection of Washington
Jefferson Roosevelt and Lincoln Borglum
totally his decision well he what he his
first sketch was of the profile of a
continental soldier of Washington then
they thought about adding Lincoln and
then one by one Jefferson and Teddy
Roosevelt but I'm sure Roosevelt
wouldn't have been there if they had not
been friends so if someone has never
been there and they've always wanted to
go how much time should they give
themselves in order to have a good
experience I think Mount Rushmore is
worth spending part of two days I think
it's great to see it in the light I urge
anybody is going there to go for the
general the larger tourist experience
but also go to treat Mount Rushmore as a
work of art if I'd like if I could add
anything is is that that with all the
Kitsch and all the tourist culture stuff
and even the the message of patriotism
all of that aside Mount Rushmore is a
terrific piece of sculpture done by a
great American sculpt sculptor and to go
there and to see it in the early morning
light which is what Borglum intended to
go see it in the evening when they turn
the lights on to walk around it to Amman
to to look at the at the carving as one
would if they were in a museum I think
is really worthwhile so they are so your
next book haven't decided
not even close it's not going to tell
you a person an issue an idea all that
John Tolliver our guest here's the cover
of the book called great white fathers
the story of the obsessive quest to
create Mount Rushmore thank you very
much thank you